let's briefly pause from the election
related stuff just to do a little hatred
mail after all why not take a listen to
this the right of the people to keep and
bear hates shall not be infringed
Patriot man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom all right and this this week's
hatred mail like most needs no
introduction let's take a listen to this
week's atria mail you're an idiot Packer
man and yes you are a socialist leftists
of all kinds always deny their left isms
you're either ignorant stupid crazy or
an evil liar because at the end of the
day you're a call activist who doesn't
understand what is collectivism
is Authority and what is
authoritarianism always stems from
Hilary lost law this is so silly like
don't you think at this point if I were
a socialist I would just say it like I'm
already getting all the downsides of
people pretending or or believing me to
be a socialist what do I gain now by
denying that I'm a socialist I'm a
Social Democrat I believe in private
ownership of businesses but I think that
we have to make sure nobody gets left
behind in our system if I were a
socialist or a communist or a Marxist I
would just tell you come on you know me
well enough use the coupon code hey tree
at 40 every time you do it 286 hey tree
it's cry when you use the coupon code
hey tree at 40 and sign up for
membership it's kind of like a middle
finger to the hey tree 'it's which i
know a lot of people in our audience
relish doing go to WWE Ackman com select
any membership and use the coupon code
hey tree at forty at checkout h80 our
IOT 4-0 it'll save you forty percent the
hey tree 'it's will cry and you'll be
supporting independent media